bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne la lecture des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de réforme du conseil économique et
social principales modifications issues
de la révision constitutionnelle de 2008
le conseil économique et social est
transformé en un conseil économique
social et environnemental pour mieux
tenir compte des préoccupations
environnementales sa composition est
également modifié in hier les députés
ont donné leur feu vert à cette réforme
les sénateurs doivent donc à leur tour
se prononcer ce matin pour que ce projet
de loi soit définitivement adopté tout
de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
bonne matinée à tous la séance s'est
ouverte le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué y at
il des observations il n'y en a pas le
procès verbal est adoptée sous les
réserves usage l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargée des
chargés d'élaborer un texte sur les
dispositions restant en discussion du
projet de loi organique relatif au
conseil économique social et
environnemental dans la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre vial rapporteur pour le sénat de
la commission mixte paritaire
même le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues le sénat est appelé
à voter la loi organique relative au
conseil économique social et
environnemental
après qu'ils étaient il ya de petits la
réforme constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 qui engageait la transformation de
cette institution dans sa mise en oeuvre
la loi organique procède à une véritable
refondation du conseil économique et
social dont les relations avec le
parlement devant d'être renforcée est
réaffirmée en sa qualité de troisième
chambre au sens même de la constitution
c'est l'article 1er de la loi organique
qui pose clairement l'objet même du
conseil économique social et
environnemental en rappelant que sa
mission est d'assurer la participation
des principales activités du pays à la
politique économique social et
environnemental la nation d'examiner les
évolutions et économiques et sociales et
environnementales et de suggérer les
adaptations qui lui paraissent
nécessaires nous avions entièrement
souscrit à la volonté l'assemblée
nationale de rétablir le fait que le
conseil doit favoriser la collaboration
des principales activités du pays afin
d'assurer une plus forte participation
politique mise en oeuvre l'article 3
conforte ce rôle
considérant que le conseil peut appeler
l'attention du gouvernement et du
parlement sur les réformes qui lui
paraissent nécessaires
nous pouvons ainsi au coeur de
l'equilibre des rôles entre les missions
qui relèvent du conseil économique
social et environnemental et les
pouvoirs des assemblées parlementaires
qui dispose désormais de la possibilité
de le consulter
cette éclipse se trouve bien évidemment
renforcée par la faculté donnée à nos
concitoyens de saisir le conseil
économique social et environnemental par
voie de pétition sur ce point monsieur
le ministre vous savez l'intérêt que
nous portons à ce que le contrôle des
signatures puisse s'effectuer par
échantillonnage tout en prévoyant que la
vie soit rendue dans un maximum d'une
année pour favoriser la saisine du
conseil le sénat a souhaité renforcer et
élargir la procédure d'urgence relatives
aux avis demandé au conseil économique
social et environnemental
concernant la représentativité la loi
organique pas référence au principe de
parité à sir assure une meilleure prise
en compte de la représentation des
femmes et l'ouverture aux associations
environnementales en même temps que la
représentation des jeunes et des
étudiants en en baissant de 25 à 18 ans
l'âge requis pour siéger au conseil tout
en conservant l'équilibré de la
répartition
entre catégories adopté par l'assemblée
nationale le sénat a tenu à procéder un
fléchage de certaines personnalités
qualifiées permettant d'enrichir la
composition du conseil en réintroduisant
la représentation des entreprises
publiques la représentativité des
activités économiques françaises à
l'étranger la demande des sénateurs des
français de l'étranger et en associant
au collège environnementale une
représentation des entreprises qui sont
au coeur de ces enjeux votre rapporteur
avait d'ailleurs proposé que les
personnalités qualifiées soit désigné
partir par le président de la république
et chacun des présents des deux
assemblées
mais monsieur le ministre vous avez
convaincu le sénat que la nomination des
personnalités qualifiées devait être
appréciée et qu'il convenait pour ce
faire que ce choix relève d'une seule
autorité
enfin il est un point qui malgré tout
reste quelque peu en suspens ou plus
précisément différé c'est celui de la
représentativité qui est
vraisemblablement une des critiques les
plus anciennes et les plus importantes
opposé au conseil économique et social
la loi organique devait d'abord intégré
à effectif constant des acteurs du monde
environnementale pour créer une
troisième un troisième pôle au sein du
sein tandis que la mise en oeuvre de la
loi d'août 2008 réformant les critères
de représentativité des syndicats ne
prendra effet qu'en 2014
il n'était dès lors pas possible d'aller
plus loin dans la réforme de la
composition du cesa sans déséquilibrer
brutalement cette institution néanmoins
il est nécessaire que le problème de la
représentativité des membres du cese un
soin à terme pris en compte par le
législateur c'est l'objet de l'article 8
bis à par lequel le sénat a intégré la
clause de revoyure qui permettra
d'évaluer la pertinence de la
composition du season tous les dix ans
et pour la première fois dès 2014
au delà de la discussion sur la nature
du dispositif proposé qui a eu lieu en
cmp je me félicite commission mixte
paritaire et partagé il d'identité de
vue sur ce point qui est important
monsieur le ministre est donc la mise en
oeuvre relève de la responsabilité du
gouvernement
la refondation entreprises de nos
saisons les outils institutionnels lui
permettant de jouer pleinement le rôle
qu'entend dû donner la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008
pour autant que l'on voudra en faire
vivre l'esprit à l'organique soumise aux
deux assemblées est un texte équilibré
au regard des attentes et des ambitions
placées dans ce nouveau conseil
économique social et environnemental
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues je
vous propose d'adopter le projet de loi
organique relatif au conseil public
social et environnemental tels qu'ils
résultent du texte proposé à la suite de
son adoption par la commission mixte
paritaire
merci monsieur henri de raincourt
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
vous avez la parole madame la présidente
monsieur le doyen sur le rapporteur
messieurs les sénateurs
ce projet de loi organique assure la
pleine transformation du conseil
économique et social en conseil
économique social et environnemental et
sa revalorisation engagé par la révision
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008
le texte qui a été adopté par la
commission mixte paritaire est le
résultat d'un travail parlementaire
approfondie conduit dans un esprit de
dialogue et de responsabilité je dois
saluer la qualité des débats qu'elle il
m'a été donnée de participer tout
particulièrement au sénat qui permis
d'aboutir à un texte je crois que le
rapporteur l'évoquait lui-même à
l'instant équilibre je tiens tout
particulièrement en cette circonstance a
remercié le président de la commission
des lois et le rapporteur monsieur jean
pierre vial de leur contribution tout à
fait
éminente et décisive pour l'élaboration
de solutions qui puissent faire l'objet
d'un large consensus la principale
difficulté de ce texte résidait dans la
recomposition nécessaire du conseil
la modification de la composition
réalisée à effectif constant la 10ème
nombreuses reprises devait traduire de
façon adéquate
la nouvelle compétence environnementale
elle devait également tenir compte des
transformations de la société française
pour garantir la représentativité de
l'institution la nouvelle composition
proposée par le gouvernement reposait
sur un équilibre fragile je les dis
aussi difficilement acquis le sénat a
comme l'assemblée nationale pris soin de
préserver cet équilibre et je tiens à
exprimer la vive gratitude du
gouvernement
cela a été rappelé votre assemblée a
souhaité également enrichir la
composition du conseil et la commission
mixte paritaire a retenu le système de
fléchage des personnalités qualifiées
mis en place à cet effet les entreprises
publiques les activités économiques
françaises à l'étranger
l'économie verte le logement social les
retraités trouveront ainsi désormais une
représentation dans les différents
contingents de personnalités qualifiées
l'institution d'une clause de revoyure
répond par ailleurs aux soucis de votre
assemblée de garantir durablement la
représentativité du nouveau conseil
économique social et environnemental
le projet de loi organique adapte par
ailleurs le fonctionnement du conseil
pour tirer toutes les conséquences de la
révision constitutionnelle le travail
d'actualisation de l' ordonnance de 1958
menée par le gouvernement
man a été amélioré par l'assemblée
nationale
plusieurs dispositions innovantes ont
aussi été adoptées pour renforcer la
dynamique de la réforme la commission
mixte paritaire a ainsi retenu la
création à l'initiative du sénat d'une
procédure de consultation en urgence ou
la fixation d'un délai maximum pour
rendre un avis sur une pétition
enfin le projet de loi organique vient
préciser les conditions de consultation
du conseil économique social et
environnemental par le parlement et
celle de sa saisine par voie de pétition
ces nouvelles voies de saisine instauré
par la constitution révisée sont
largement ouvertes par le texte tout en
préservant le conseil d'excès qui serait
préjudiciable à la réalisation de sa
mission et à la qualité de ses travaux
répond dans un souci d'équilibré
ces dispositions ont été adoptées
conforme par les deux assemblées
ainsi après un examen minutieux par les
deux chambres du parlement le projet de
loi organique me paraît pleinement
répondre à l'ensemble des objectifs
fixés par le constituant mais messieurs
madame et messieurs les sénateurs
l'adoption de ce projet de loi organique
sera un moment majeur dans la vie du
conseil économique social et
environnemental pelure plus
représentatif et donc plus légitime
moderniser et donc plus efficace
le conseil pourra prendre toute sa place
au coeur de nos institutions et de notre
société
sa contribution sera attendu pour
permettre à notre démocratie de faire
face aux défis majeurs
de notre temps merci messieurs mini sont
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur simon sutour
dans le groupe socialiste madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
ultime étape de la réforme du conseil
économique social et environnemental
cette séance relatives aux conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire qui
s'est tenue le 18 mai dernière va nous
permettre de rappeler ici un certain
nombre de propositions qui ont été plus
ou moins prises en considération il faut
cependant noter que le travail des deux
assemblées a largement permis
d'améliorer le texte présenté par le
gouvernement
je tiens à saluer le courage aussi de
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des lois jean pierre vial qui a pris des
positions intéressantes sur de nombreux
points de cette réforme notamment sur le
droit de pétition encore sur la
nomination des personnalités qualifiées
et qui n'a malheureusement pas toujours
été soutenu par la majorité sénatoriale
nos positions n'était pas très souvent
éloignés des siennes au niveau du texte
découlant de la cmp hormis quelques
ajustements dans de rédactionnel
le texte est en tout point similaire à
celui que nous avons pu voter le 5 mai
dernier en séance publique les sénateurs
socialistes ont néanmoins permis lors de
la cmp de maintenir des dispositions
jugées utiles alors que les députés de
la majorité souhaitaient les supprimer
je pense ici à la clause de revoyure
c'est pourquoi mon analyse sera en tous
points conforme à celle que j'avais pu
avoir ce jour là à savoir un certain
nombre d'avancées
et beaucoup de regrets au sujet des
avancées comme je viens de le souligner
la cmp n'a pas modifié grâce à l'appui
des sénateurs socialistes
l'article 8 bis a du projet de loi
relatif à la clause de revoyure qui
prévoit un rapport au parlement ce qui
permet aux assemblées de se saisir de
l'évolution de la composition du cee est
ce tous les dix ans avec une mise en
oeuvre pour la première fois dans quatre
ans comme on vous l'avait indiqué
monsieur le rapporteur
il s'agit d'une avancée importante que
nous devons au sénat la cmp à l'instar
du sénat n'a pas remis en cause non plus
l'apport de l'assemblée nationale
concernant la représentation du
mouvement coopératif agricole en
maintenant lors de l'examen en séance
depuis lors de la scène dès les avancées
obtenues par nos collègues députés
c'est un signal fort envoyé à
destination du monde agricole qui
connaît une crise aiguë au sujet des
regrets nous souhaitions améliorer la
représentation des français de
l'étranger des acteurs du logement
social
des représentants des entreprises
publiques mais nous n'avons pas été
suivis sur ces trois points nous n'avons
pas été suivies non plus sur la mise en
oeuvre d'une stricte parité homme femme
sur la nomination des personnalités
qualifiées ou encore sur la suppression
des personnalités associées je ne vais
pas revenir aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble
des articles du projet de loi
cependant s'il convient de reconnaître
qu'à l'issue de cette réforme le
fonctionnement du conseil économique
social et environnemental sera largement
améliorée
je pense qu'au sujet de la répartition
et de la nomination de ses représentants
la réforme est pour le moins timide sur
la représentation bien que celle ci ne
soit plus figées puisque il pourra y
avoir des ajustements périodiques pour
tenir compte de l'évolution des
différentes composantes la société
française je m'étonne que l'opportunité
qui nous avait il nous a été donné dès
aujourd'hui de pouvoir avoir un conseil
économique social et environnemental
vraiment représentatifs n'ait pas été
saisie en effet je pense que nos
propositions dans ce domaine allait dans
le bon sens notamment celles relatives à
la représentation des français de
l'étranger telles qu'elles ont été
défendues par notre collègue richard
yung ou encore celle relative à la
représentation des entreprises publiques
elle était je crois des plus mesuré sur
le volet parité article 6 sur
l'amélioration de la prise en compte de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes article 9 bis nos
propositions la hausse la hausse il
encore n'ont pas été retenus je reste
pourtant persuadé que sur ces deux
points en particulier sera nécessaire à
moyen terme de procéder à des
ajustements en fin de manière plus
générale de points essentiels du projet
de loi tel qu'il nous est présenté
aujourd'hui sont pour le moins
problématique et viennent entacher assez
gravement la portée de cette réforme
je pense ici à la désignation des
personnalités qualifiées et à la non
suppression des personnalités associées
lors des débats en commission des lois
le rapporteur a retiré son amendement
relatif à la désignation des
personnalités qualifiées du conseil
économique social environnemental par
tiers par le président de la république
le président du sénat et le président de
l'assemblée nationale
c'est pourquoi lors de l'examen en
séance publique nous avons déposé un
amendement identique qui n'a pas été
retenue je pense que l'objectif majeur
de la réforme
outre l'extension des attributions du
conseil en matière d'environnement
son rapprochement avec les citoyens
grâce une saisine par voie de pétition
était bien évidemment de renforcer les
liens avec le pouvoir législatif et le
parlement sur ce dernier point non plus
force est de constater que la réforme
n'est pas aboutie pour conclure je
souhaite aussi exprimer mon profond
regret sur l'article 9 articles relatifs
à la catégorie personnalités associées
et sur le fait que notre amendement
visant à supprimer cette catégorie
demain on en titulaire
discrétionnairement nommé par le
gouvernement n'ait pas été adoptée
la suppression de cet anachronisme
aurait fait honneur à notre assemblée
ait mis fin à des pratiques d'une autre
époque
voilà mes chers collègues nos remarques
suite à la commission mixte paritaire
sur
réforme du conseil économique et social
et environnemental compte tenu des
éléments que je viens de développer le
groupe socialiste s'abstiendra si chers
collègues
la parole est un monsieur jacques mézard
pour le rassemblement démocratique
social et européen
je
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord merci à notre rapporteur
pour la qualité de son travail et sa
volonté de faire évoluer positivement
cette institution le projet de loi
organique relatif aux conseillers
économiques nous revient aujourd'hui
après une seule lecture dans chaque
assemblée conséquences de la procédure
accélérée engagée par le gouvernement de
manière liminaire nous pouvons constater
que le cheminement de ce texte a encore
illustré la surcharge du calendrier
parlementaire et ce projet de loi ne
déroge malheureusement pas ce qui est en
passe de devenir la norme déposé sur le
bureau de l'assemblée le 25 août 2009
il aura attendu plus de huit mois pour
qu'ils soient discutées par nos
collègues députés en procédure pourtant
accéléré du fait de la priorité donnée à
d'autres textes médiatique dans la
foulée néanmoins ce texte fut débattue
en un mois successivement à l'assemblée
au sénat et en cmp
ce n'est quand même pas d'une grande
logique ce texte constitue constitue une
évolution avec des côtés positifs du
s'agit d'une évolution ne mise pas d'une
révolution
exactement ancien ministre donc nous
avons dans ce texte une partie
d'éléments qui nous paraissent positif
donc notre groupe soit s'abstiendra soit
votera pour certains de ses membres pour
donc personne ne s'opposera à ce texte
sur le fond les conclusions de la cmp
s'inscrivent dans le fil des discussions
auxquelles ont donné lieu l'examen du
projet de loi devant notre haute
assemblée la cmp ayant conservé
certaines des dispositions qui avait été
adoptée ici
la procédure de consultation en urgence
l'encadrement de la procédure d'avis sur
les pétitions l'obligation de prendre en
compte les avis du conseil dans les
études d'impact annexée au projet de loi
le cas échéant nous en prenons acte et
nous nous en satisfaisant
nous nous félicitons également qui a été
retenu après quelques débats
la proposition de notre rapporteur voté
par le sénat tendant à obliger le
gouvernement à envisager périodiquement
la révision de la composition du conseil
économique afin de garantir le maintien
d'une réelle représentativité de cette
institution
le sénat avait choisi de prévoir un
rapport suivi d'un débat parce qu'il
s'agissait du seul moyens envisageables
pour assurer que la question soit
évoquée tous les dix ans nous savons en
effet tous que la question de la
représentativité des membres du conseil
constitue un point d'achoppement
depuis sa création elle avait déjà été
soulevée en 1963 une seule réforme était
intervenu en 1984 avant la discussion du
présent projet de loi organique
nous estimons nous que la clause
décennal de revoyure ainsi introduite
permettra d'essayer de prévenir la
sédimentation et l'immobilisme
éventuelle du conseil économique afin de
garantir que sa composition reflète au
mieux
l'image du monde économique social
environnemental de notre pays qu'ils
soient davantage une institution à l'
expertise solide et diversifiée ce qui
est loin d'être compatible avec le
processus de choix des heureux désigné
s'ouvre néanmoins aussi bien les débats
tenus en première lecture que ceux de la
cmp
non pas régler un certain nombre de
problématiques que nous évoquions tous
ici même le 5 mai dernier en premier
lieu subsiste le problème car en lit il
en est bien et notre collègue simon
sutour vient de le rappeler des 72
membres de sexion associés désigné dans
les conditions qui viennent d'être
rappelés
nous demeurons opposé au principe même
de ce train de nominations qui répond le
plus souvent à des considérations pas
toujours très transparents ou trop et
pas toujours conformes à ce que devrait
être l'intérêt général et l'expertisé
requise d'un membre du conseil le
rapport chartier de 2002 évoqué déjà en
des termes peu amènes l'inutilité de ces
conseillers dans l'existence fragilise
l'équilibré déjà fragile de
l'institution nous n'avons pas été
convaincus par l'argumentation qui nous
a été opposée et par celle du
gouvernement pour qui le choix de ces
personnalités qualifiées devait être
apprécié globalement et qu'il devait en
conséquence être effectuée par une
autorité unique
dès lors puisque rien n'a changé sur ce
point nous persistons à penser que le
maintien de ses conseillers nommés de
façon discrétionnaire constitue une
survivance fort regrettable je ne pense
pas qu'on contribuer de la sorte à doter
le conseil de la crédibilité de la
légitimité qu'ils recherchent pour enfin
trouver une place solide dans notre
paysage institutionnel
en second lieu nous regrettons le
compromis auquel est parvenue la cmp
s'agissant de la représentation des
entreprises publiques
parmi les personnalités
qualifiés du secteur économique à
l'article 6 actuellement représentée par
dix conseillers
elles ne le seront plus que par deux
représentants au vu des conclusions de
la cmp alors que ces entreprises pèsent
d'un poids majeur dans notre pays
le sénat avait d'ailleurs initialement
prévus à l'initiative de notre
rapporteur à l'unanimité me semble-t-il
de la commission de porter ce chiffre à
3 de leur amener d'ailleurs à 3 pour
permettre la représentation d activité
économique française à l'étranger
ce compromis aboutit au final à une sous
représentation des entreprises publiques
par rapport aux 27 représentants des
entreprises privées industrielles
commerciales et de service et nous
regrettons ce déséquilibre en troisième
lieu et en conclusion nous constatons
que le dispositif de saisine du conseil
par le parlement rendue possible par la
révision constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 est restée en l'état en limitant ce
droit de saisine malgré d'autres
avancées comme des pétitions nous avons
un texte qui introduit un filtrage qui
réserve de fait un droit de veto à la
majorité
nous considérons que c'est dommage et
nous constatons à ce niveau là qu'un
effort aurait pu être réalisée pour
conclure si le conseil économique doit
avoir une efficacité
monsieur le ministre dans nos
institutions c'est par la qualité de son
expertise
il est évident que cette qualité passe
par la compétence et l'expérience des
hommes amenés à y siéger
en tout état de cause les conclusions de
la cmp n'ont pas levé tous les doutes
qui étaient les nôtres en première
lecture ceci étant nous confirmerons
notre vote avec une répartition de nos
votes entre l'abstention et le vote pour
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à mme anna nicole borvo
cohen seat pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen si natal parti de
gauche
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues nous l'avons
dit lors de l'examen du projet de loi
organique comme d'ailleurs lors de la
révision constitutionnelle
la réforme du conseil économique et
social et sa transformation en conseil
économique et social et environnemental
de nous paraissait tout à fait opportune
nous sommes favorables bien entendu à sa
consultation par le parlement et à sa
saisine par le citoyen est donc certain
nombre d'évolutions sont positives
nous avons cependant émis un certain
nombre de critiques comme mes collègues
sur la nomination des personnalités
qualifiées par le pouvoir exécutif et
sans qu'il soit précisé quelle est la
nature des qualifications requises ce
qui est un problème concernant les
causes économiques et sociales sur la
suppression des représentants des
entreprises publiques sur l'absence de
représentants des organismes de logement
social sur la diminution de la
représentation du monde agricole
enfin et surtout sur l'absence de
véritable bougie
quant à la prise en compte des avis du
conseil économique et social et
environnemental
nous avons lors de l'examen au sénat
présenté des amendements correspondant à
ces remarques qui n'ont pas été retenus
par le sénat ni bien entendu par la
suite
le texte issu de la cmp est peu
différent de celui qui a été adopté au
sénat qui était effectivement en qu'il y
avait un certain nombre d'amis
d'amélioration qui ont été retenus
d'ailleurs les inflexions au texte
initial adopté au sénat est adoptée en
cmp sont plutôt positifs
l'ajout d'un représentant du logement
social ces qui est effectivement il
une lacune importante la procédure de
saisie d'urgence du cs eu la possibilité
de contester la nomination d'un membre
devant le conseil d'état
la clause de revoyure tout ça a été
plutôt des améliorations cependant les
raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
abstenus de moeurs qui tiennent bien
entendu à la sous représentation des
entreprises publiques qui avait
complètement disparu et le fait d'en
avoir dans avoir pris 2,9 et le nombre
de 2 nous parler sous-estimé le les
entreprises publiques et services
publics dans ce pays les raisons
principales de notre position tiennent
principalement les raisons principales
tiennent au système de nomination des
personnalités qualifiées
c'est à dire à la toute puissance de
l'exécutif et au pouvoir discrétionnaire
on le sait de l'exécutif pour nommer ces
personnalités et à l'absence de réel
dispositif de suivi des habits du
conseil économique social et
environnemental comme
qui font que bon certes le conseil
s'étoffe
il trompe peut-être plus en compte la
réalité sociale mais ceci dit ce qui dit
n'a pas beaucoup d'effet continuera ne
pas avoir beaucoup d'effets me
semble-t-il ce qui est regrettable
donc pour ces raisons nous maintiendrons
notre vote d'abstention sur le texte
merci madame la présidente
la parole est un monsieur richard yung
pour le groupe socialiste
voilà ma la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crois
que nous avons un texte améliorée après
les travaux au sénat et la cmp
je voudrais rappeler tout l'intérêt que
nous portons au conseil économique et
social dans un pays comme le nôtre où le
débat est toujours une chose difficile
où on a du mal à dialoguer c'est sans
doute une responsabilité collective où
nous avons beaucoup de mal à élaborer
des consensus
le conseil économique et social
vous le savez est un des rares lieux où
les représentants des salariés dialogue
véritablement et efficacement je crois
avec les représentants des employeurs et
c'est vraiment une
une spécificité importante et qu'il faut
souligner d'ailleurs le succès si j'ose
dire qu'a eue le conseil économique et
social avec son essaimage à travers le
monde
je crois une soixantaine de conseils
économiques et sociaux montre que c'est
une structure
contrairement à ce que beaucoup croient
c'est une structure utile et il faut
bien sûr la faire évoluer et c'est le
sens du texte et prendre en compte les
grandes tendances de la société c'était
et c'est là la finalité de votre texte
est de ce point de vue il ya un certain
nombre d'améliorations que je veux
souligner bien sûr l'ouverture au souci
de l'environnement au développement
durable
la saisine et donc nous étions ouverts
et prêts à chercher un accord des
compromis mais et je reviens à ce que je
disais au début comme d'habitude toutes
nos propositions et bien son
se heurte au mur de fer de la majorité
gouvernementale et mes collègues l'ont
déjà rappelé je fais que passer en revue
ses différentes propositions
donc je pense qu'elle n'était pas
révolutionnaire dont je ne pense pas
qu'elle mettait en cause les équilibres
du texte et non nous pensions peut être
naïvement qu'elle n'améliorerait on a
parlé de la représentation des
entreprises publiques qui est quand même
réduite a plus qu'une portion congrue la
représentation du mouvement consumérisme
de l'économie sociale j'ose à peine
parler des français de l'étranger parce
qu'on va me dire que je plaide pro domo
mais bon les représentants disparaissent
ils sont dieu merci
remplacé au moins portion congrue par un
représentant de l'économie et des
entreprises françaises à l'étranger
merci de vos efforts mais on a
l'impression quand même d'une d'une
diminution capitis et puis le problème
important qui a déjà été évoqué
l'inflation des personnalités qualifiées
40 au lieu de 15 alors vous allez me
dire c'est facile d'être vertueux quand
on n'est pas quand on n'est pas aux
affaires mais justement nous nous
prenions là un engagement non seulement
pour vous si j'ose dire mais aussi pour
nous l'avenir aurait porté cette réforme
sur la les conditions de nomination des
personnalités qualifiées dont on voit
bien que elles vont rester une sorte de
viviez à la disposition de l'exécutif
pour remercier les services rendus
quand c'est pas pire la suppression des
personnalités associées
qui sont soumis à la même critique et
enfin le problème de la parité hommes
femmes
voilà donc ces raisons je les fais que
les évoquer vous les connaissez bien
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
nous pensions qu'elle améliorerait le
texte et je continue à le penser
c'est dommage qu'on n'arrive pas à
s'entendre c'est sur des choses aussi
simple et aussi banal donc vous
connaissez notre position nous nous
abstiendrons mais j'irai à regret merci
merci chaque collègue
la parole est à monsieur françois
fortassin pour l'heure déçu
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon
excellent collègue jacques mézard et
andré aux formes
donc je me dispenserait d'intervenir à
nouveau sur ce plan là moi je veux me
situer sur la position du citoyen de
base que je diviserai honteuse catégorie
1re catégorie celui qui est totalement
ignare dans celui-là il dit rien par
rapport au conseil économique et social
dont il sait pas ce que c'est et puis
celui qui est un peu plus avertis et qui
trouve dans cette noble institution un
certain nombre de deux défauts d'abord
le caractère totalement discrétionnaire
des nominations par le gouvernement
ensuite ses conseillers surnuméraires il
faut bien entendu que le citoyen de base
à aller chercher de quoi il s'agit mais
il a le sentiment que de toute façon il
ya une chose qui est pas clair et en
réalité je crois que le fait fondamental
ici c'est que ça sert à recaser les
recalés du suffrage universel
et puis un certain nombre de serviteurs
dit loyaux qui ont pas forcément servi
la république pendant toute leur
carrière mais qui ont été des
carriéristes tout à fait exemplaire et
qui en tant que telle mérite bien
entendu quelques récompenses
alors cette institution est donc frappé
en sont celles d'un certain nombre de
défauts et s'il n'est pas étonnant à ce
niveau comme l'a remarqué jacques mézard
que le caractère totalement
discrétionnaire et au parc dès sa
nomination apparaît aujourd hui
anachronique mais surtout quand on
traite les conseillers le conseiller de
celle de second rang soit c'est pas très
gentil
soit ça corresponde à une réalité ce qui
est plus grave aussi on observe aussi
que la plupart ses conseillers brille
essentiellement non pas pour leurs
qualités expertises alors qu'ils ont été
nommé nonce pour ça mais pour une
absence chronique est rédhibitoire et le
droit ensuite exclusive à la majorité
est un peu difficile à supporter
de la même façon le fait que les
entreprises publiques soit sous
représentés nous paraît quelque chose de
dommages fiable comme cela a été dit et
malgré les améliorations qui a eu de la
part du sénat pour faire en sorte que le
texte soit un peu plus je dirais
acceptable
comme la plupart des collègues m'ont
outre je m'abstiendrai sur ce texte
contre mais avec beaucoup de regret
parce qu'on aurait pu faire me semble
t'il quelque chose de parfaitement
rénovée sur une institution qui me
semble-t-il de mériter merci la
discussion générale est close nous
passons la discussion du texte élaboré
par la commission mixte paritaire
je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 alinéa 12 du règlement du
sénat examinant après l'assemblée
nationale le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire
il se prononce par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte sur les articles 1er
à 16 je suis saisi d'aucun amendements y
at il une demande de parole sur l'un
quelconque de ces articles il n'y en a
pas le vote est réservée conformément à
l'article 42 alinéa 12 u règlement je
vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de l'organique dans la rédaction
résultant du texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote oui chaque collègue les suffrages
merci madame la présidente
comme la présidente monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
la réforme constitutionnelle du 23
juillet 2008 voulue par le président de
la république engagé la rénovation du
conseil économique et social créé par l'
ordonnance du 29 décembre 58
désormais le conseil économique social
et environnemental a pour mission de
prendre en compte les problématiques
environnementales
les membres du groupe ump et moi même
nous en réjouissons
outre cet élargissement de compétence du
céser au domaine environnemental le
projet de loi organique que nous sommes
appelés à voter aujourd'hui temps d'une
part à modifier son fonctionnement pour
le rendre plus proche du parlement et
d'autre part à modifier sa composition
pour qu'il soit mieux représentatif de
la population active française
la prise en compte des évolutions de la
société française ainsi que de son
hétérogénéité ont été au centre de notre
réflexion dans le cadre de cette réforme
afin de faire du conseil économique une
véritable institution démocratique ayant
pour vocation à de donner son avis sur
les politiques publiques
le conseil comptera 233 membres et sera
structuré en trois grands pôles le pôle
économique avec 140 membres
le pôle social composé de 60 et le pôle
environnemental nouvellement créée avec
33 membres
ainsi l'environnement devient le
troisième pilier du conseil
la saisine de ce dernier est automatique
surtout plan ou projet de loi de
programmation à caractère économique
social et environnemental
c'est une bonne chose ensuite les
possibilités de saisine sont élargies
aux citoyens et aux membres de nos
assemblées parlementaires
ce faisant le projet de loi organique
instaure des liens plus étroits entre le
parlement et le conseil qui devient plus
accessible à nos concitoyens
en outre la crise la question de la
représentativité du conseil est pour
nous essentiel ainsi plusieurs
dispositions modifiant la composition du
conseil permettent de le rendre meilleur
d'abord afin de prévenir de parvenir
pardon années un rééquilibrage entre les
différentes catégories représentées il
fallait accepter de diminuer la
représentation de catégories existantes
ou encore d'en supprimer d'autres
c'est afin d'obtenir une composition en
phase avec les réalités sociologiques de
la société française
que les jeunes seront représentés au
sein du conseil où que la représentation
des professions libérales des
associations et fondations sera
renforcée dans cette même logique le
projet de loi tient compte du fait que
les femmes ne représentent que 22 % des
effectifs du conseil alors qu'elles
représentent la moitié de la population
active
il était important d'inscrire dans ce
texte la parité pour la désignation des
membres du conseil
par ailleurs afin de maintenir la
représentation des entreprises publiques
il fallait leur réserver deux des dix
sièges dévolus à des personnalités
qualifiées dans le domaine économique
c'est là un des autres apports de notre
haute assemblée nous nous en félicitons
je me réjouis tout particulièrement que
le texte ait été modifié par le sénat
afin qu'une personnalité représentent
les activités économiques françaises à
l'étranger
la suppression de la représentation des
français de l'étranger au sein du
conseil a été justifiée par le fait
qu'en tant que représentant des français
établis hors de france
nous disposons de notre propre assemblée
et que à compter de 2012
onze députés représenteront les français
l'étranger cependant le conseil
économique assure la participation et la
collaboration des différents acteurs de
la vie économique sociale et
environnementale du pays à la politique
du gouvernement
c'est à ce titre que les français les
étrangers y sont représentées depuis 84
or il y a aujourd'hui presque trois fois
plus de français établis hors de france
qu'en 84 c'est pourquoi il était
essentiel à l'heure de la mondialisation
où le commerce extérieur fait vivre un
français sur quatre que les français
expatriés et leurs places dans
l'assemblée représentant les forces
vives de la nation
enfin je souhaiterais souligner
l'excellent travail de notre rapporteur
notre collègue jean pierre vial à
l'initiative duquel deux modifications
majeures ont permis de pallier les
lacunes du dispositif voté à l'assemblée
nationale d'une part les échanges du
conseil économique social et
environnemental avec ses homologues
régionaux européens et étrangers sont
désormais explicitement reconnu et promu
d'autre part une procédure de
consultation en urgence du conseil
économique social et environnemental par
le gouvernement ou par une assemblée a
été prévu cela était indispensable pour
combler le décalage qui peut exister
entre le temps du conseil et le temps
politique
au vu de toutes ces remarques le groupe
ump votera le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire
je vous remercie merci en chat collègues
il n'y a pas d'autres demandes des
messieurs quoi t'as pas dans heroes mais
mes chers collègues ce texte améliore à
l'évidence le rôle comme la composition
du conseil économique social et
environnemental et on ne peut que s'en
féliciter
renforcer la place de cette assemblée
dans l'ordre dans l'ensemble
institutionnel est donc une bonne chose
se donnera plus de moyens plus de
compétences plus de pouvoirs et on peut
s'en féliciter
sa composition a été rénové en est
arrivé après des discussions très
difficiles que l'on peut comprendre à un
équilibre et donc je m'en félicite
mais permettez-moi de simplement
remarquer que j'aurais préféré un
équilibre peut être un peu plus si vous
parlez l'expression équilibré on verra à
l'avenir ce que cela va donner
ouvrir cette assemblée à l'environnement
est une excellente chose
est-ce que cela c'est fait se fait dans
des proportions qui paraissent justes
on verra à l'usagé car il faut pas
oublier que le conseil économique et
social autrefois représentaient les
forces vives de la nation et que le
conseil économique social
environnemental va continuer à les
représenter sous une autre forme
mais il ne faudrait pas que les forces
vives au lieu d'être transcender puisse
être au contraire amoindrie par
certaines positions difficiles parfois à
comprendre l'expérience nous le montrera
mais le challenge valait la peine d'être
tentée
voilà pourquoi bien sûr je me rallie
avec joie à la position du groupe ump
dont je fais partie bien sûr merci chers
collègues je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de l'organique dans
la rédaction résultant du texte proposé
par la commission mixte paritaire en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public et de droit
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront aux locataires
bulletins blancs ceux qui souhaitent
voter contre un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
ouais
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
à
non
voici le résultat du scrutin numéro 2
105 sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
organique relatif au conseil économique
social et environnemental nombre de
votants 339 nombre de suffrages exprimés
185 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 93 pour l'adoption 185 contre 0
le sénat a définitivement adopté le
projet de loi organique
c'est la fin de cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire cet après midi
15h bonne journée tôt sur public sénat